um thank you for the intro so just to
kick things off uh want to say I'm very
excited to be here today chatting with
you about snowflakes native application
framework specifically how it's allowing
uh app developers to bring applications
closer to where the data lives uh in
fact in this case in the exact same
environment so Snowflake and also giving
app creators the opportunity to uh
package it up list that Co list that
application on the snowflake Marketplace
and if they really want to monetize it
and unlock new revenue streams and I'll
get into all the details of that in just
a moment uh today will be a Hands-On lab
so build and deploy your first snowflake
native application using mostly python
about 90 95% python little bit of SQL
just to set things up um and I'll go
into all the resources and things that
you'll need to be able to follow along
uh in the lab shortly um as was
mentioned earlier my name is Gilberto
I'm a developer Advocate at snowflake
I've been in the space of all things
developer education experience for about
a decade now uh and so so yeah I'm
really excited to be here let's go ahead
and kick things off the agenda that I'd
like to cover today is first I'll give
you an overview of the snowflake native
at framework so what it is how you can
use it I'll then demo a snowflake native
application running in my snowflake
account and then we'll dive into the lab
today so that you can follow along and
build that same application uh with
me all right so if uh and this is
getting to that first question that that
was asked if you are interested in
following along in the lab there are few
things that you're going to need uh
number one you're going to need a
snowflake account whether that's a trial
account or otherwise you can create a
free trial account at sign up.
snowflake. comom the only thing that I
ask is as you create it please select
AWS as the underlying cloud provider as
you set that account up and this is the
first thing that I'll call out now
because it's the thing that will require
uh a bit more time for you to do so just
you know three to five minutes and I
just want to make sure you get a head
start on that so um yeah if you're
interested in following along please
create your snowflake trial account at
sign up. snowflake. pick AWS as your
underlying cloud provider for that
account there are two lab resources that
I'm going to refer to today um one is a
quick start one is a repo the quick
start basically covers all the steps
that I'll be able to cover here today
and the reason I'm sharing it here is
more for reference and I'll paste the
links here in a bit is more for
reference um in case that you uh fall
back or get stuck on a certain step you
have all the steps um in the quick start
in case you want to complete the guide
uh at a later time and then the repo um
contains all the source code for the
application and so uh let me go ahead
and paste those
links into the chat so here's a quick
start I'm dropping it into the
chat and
here is the repo keep those open for now
I won't go into the details of the them
just yet I'll show you exactly what they
each contain shortly but just kind of
keep those open in separate tabs for
now and then the last thing that you'll
need is a code Editor to be able to
browse the app source code this is
optional you can also browse the app
code using GitHub of course that's going
to be a little more cumbersome as you
navigate the directory structure within
GitHub within the repo um and so that's
why I shared um that's why I shared the
repo in case you would like to clone it
and then open up your own preferred code
Editor to kind of quickly browse through
those folders um so that's optional but
again you'll need a snowflake account a
trial count and then the resources here
that I've dropped into the
chat all right so with that um what are
we going to be building today today
we're going to be building a snowflake
native application with a use case
focused on uh supply chain analysis I
will get into the details of the entire
scenario as we start building it but I
just wanted to quickly put the
screenshot up here and show you what it
kind of like looks and feels like so you
can see this application is running in a
snowflake account um I have several
graphs here that is that are visualizing
the data that's in my snowflake account
um and you know this is a screenshot so
I I can't navigate and click stuff in it
um just just yet I'll show you what it
looks like in a bit but I just kind of
want to give you a sense of what the
application what an application can do
um in this case we're visualizing some
data but you can think about all sorts
of other use cases for applications you
can think about uh enriching data you
can think about
uh running an llm inside of a native app
all sorts of things which I'll cover at
later later point in the presentation
but here's kind of what we're going to
be building
towards all right so with that um I'd
love to First hear from you all through
comments in the chat um for folks that
have heard of or have used streamlet
could you please maybe drop a note into
the chat like hey yeah I've heard of it
or yes I've used it before I'm just kind
of trying to see where folks are
when it comes to app development with
all things
Python and no worries if you haven't
heard of it no worries if you haven't
used it so I see a couple of people
Brandon Tom
sujit okay cool some people that are new
to it thank you Patrick so if you're not
familiar with streamlet streamlet is a
super powerful open-source python
library for creating uh applications
entirely in Python and so I have this
really quick like 40 second video that
quickly shows like the gist of what
streamlit can do um and so you can see
here I have there's a there's a python
file my app.py with just a few lines of
code I am creating my the front end for
my application I'm not needing to write
any HTML or css or use any fancy
frontend Frameworks if you really wanted
to you could quickly deploy this to the
community Cloud it's free and then you'd
get a URL and then you can share it with
your with anyone so that's streamlet uh
the reason that I ask about streamlet is
because uh about a year ago snowflake
acquired the company behind streamlet
and so my next question um and I'm
curious through more comments in the
chat
is how many folks here have heard of
streamlit in
Snowflake so I I see some comments here
that streamlet is great totally agree um
let's see yeah so a lot of folks uh so
some folks have heard of stream in
Snowflake looks like a good chunk of
folks have not it is exactly what it
sounds like so what I just mentioned
earlier about streamlet all that
functionality is now available to you
natively in Snowflake and so with
snowflake inside of snowflake you can
now build streamlet apps that you could
share among accounts that are in the
same snowflake organization and the cool
thing about this model is that the
application is running not just in
snowflakes govern security perimeter but
right next to the data um that that app
is using so here's like a quick
screenshot of what that looks like a
stream leaden snowflake app if you're
interested in trying out streamling in
Snowflake you can today if you have a
snowflake account that's running on AWS
coming to the other major Cloud
providers very soon but here's kind of
the gist of what a stream and snowflake
app looks like and so the reason that I
now ask about stream and snowflake is
because today we're going to be talking
about the snowflake native application
framework and the snowflake native
application framework takes this stream
lid and snowflake model to the next
level and so with the with that
framework you can now package up your
stream lid and snowflake app or your
data app and distribute it to distribute
that app to um anyone that's browsing
snowflake so much like the experience
that you have today when you pick up
your smartphone you go to the App Store
you're browsing a lot of apps created by
all sorts of creators that's a similar
kind of experience now with the
snowflake native app framework where now
folks who are creating these
applications can package them up list
them on the snowflake Marketplace and
make them widely available to new new uh
users and if you really want to you
could monetize that application um and
unlock revenue streams that way so
that's the gist of it here that's what
the snowflake native app framework in uh
you know just a few sentences is before
I kind of move uh further with this
there are two core personas that I'm
going to be referencing today uh number
one the folks that are creating the
applications who are writing the code
packaging it up listening on the
marketplace I'm going to refer to them
as providers and then the folks who are
actually using the application so
they're discovering it on the
marketplace or installing it and running
in in their snowflake account I'm going
to use the term consumers to refer to
them and it's important to keep these
two personas in mind because as we think
about uh throughout the lab as we build
that app it's important to orient
yourself um and kind of put yourself in
the shoes of either the app provider or
the consumer so that you can kind of
understand um how the application is
working and the use case that it is
intended to
solve and so some pretty neat benefits
for application providers how exactly
are you going to be building the
snowflake native application it's not
called native just because the apps are
running in Snowflake that is a big piece
of it but also the vast majority of the
technologies that are used to build that
application or stream or snowflake
Technologies so any kind of application
logic or data Transformations you could
use with snow Parker python um you could
also you're going to be using streamlet
which is why I mentioned earlier to
build a front end um and then you also
would be able to use any of the
snowflake Primitives that you're already
used to so userdefined functions
userdefined table functions store
procedures tasks external functions all
of that is still programmatically
available to you and able for you to
you're able to package that up in your
application
logic uh as I mentioned earlier for app
providers you can drive Revenue by by
listing the application on the
marketplace and attaching a billing
model to it and I'll dive into the
details of that billing model looks like
in a bit and then because the
application is running in Snowflake for
anyone who's considering using your
application some typical concerns are
around security around whether or not uh
around procurement but since a consumer
the user of the application is also on
snowflake a lot of those concerns are
kind of alleviated and taken care of
because the application is running
entirely in Snowflake on data that's
typically already in Snowflake as
well on the consumer side um you can
quickly and easily discover the apps on
the marketplace today if you've used a
Marketplace you can find data sets on
there proprietary data sets at um
sometimes so the experience is very
similar you would go to the marketplace
find an an app that meets your use case
for your data install it and run it and
then similar to what I mentioned for
providers any security or procurement
hurdle scare they're basically already
cleared because again everything is
going to be running in Snowflake on data
that you
own what does the experience for uh a
provider look like when they're building
a snowflake native app you bring your
own tools to the workflow um you could
work in uh snowflake worksheets inside
of the snowflake UI or you could use a
visual uh Vis vs code extension that we
have for snowflake you don't have to use
that extension you could or you can work
Direct in vs code in combination with
other CLI tools that we provide you're
going to be using all the same snowflake
Primitives that I mentioned earlier
there's a bit of SQL that you can use
for scripting exactly what's going to
happen when that application installed
is installed in account your UI is going
to be built using streamlet you're able
to test and that share that app within
your within the same account and then I
have this last Point here I have Plus
spcs for folks that are not familiar
Snow part containers Services is a
feature that snowflake announced uh at
their annual conference this past summer
which basically allows you to uh in
combination with Native apps anything
that could be containerized anything at
this point um could run in a native app
in the future using snow park container
services so I mentioned today about how
you don't have to worry about using
react or some other Frameworks for
building let's say the front end of your
your native application but we do get
questions on hey can I run that can I
run this stack as a native app today you
cannot but in future it when we pair
this with the snow snow park container
services feature you'll be able to
basically run anything that can be
containerized any app for for instance
um inside of a native app and so that'll
launch in private preview pretty soon so
keep an eye out for
that I talked earlier about billing
models it's not just it doesn't have to
be just you know a consumer paying a
fixed um a fixed onetime payment when
they first install it it's pretty
flexible so for example you could attach
a billing model that drives revenue on
on a query that is run in that
application or on specific events that
you consider to be billable or maybe
there is a base monthly fee kind of like
a a subscription so it's pretty flexible
and you get to Define that and then
after the application is listed on the
marketplace the way you manage it the
way you operate it and maintain it say
there's a bug fix you can quickly spin
up a patch and snowflake will manage
that release for you and so we'll roll
out that change to make sure that that
bug fix that you implemented is rolled
out seamlessly and then on the flip side
um if consumers have opted to um so if
users of the app have opted to share any
logs um associated with the application
you could look at that and just get some
more insight on what might be crashing
uh or what might not be working as
intended
for folks who are using a snowflake
native app here's what the experience
look like you find them on the snowflake
Marketplace every single application on
the marketplace has already undergone a
Security review by snowflake we we check
everything just to make sure that
there's nothing malicious that could
affect a consumer account we of course
want to mitigate and and prevent any
security threats and
abuse as you're thinking about
installing an application you're able to
review all the actions and the
permissions that that uh application is
going to uh request of you when you
install it and then you can also view an
apps monetization model before you
purchase it once you start using it
you're going to purchase your the
application using your existing
snowflake capacity commitment there are
some apps out there that you might be
able to try with free trials and so free
trials is another feature that's
supported for app
providers and then you can take that
application run it in your your account
and just see how it run see how it works
see you know get a sense for what that
application does and of course as I
mentioned you can grant any object level
privileges in your account to that data
Maybe the application says hey I need I
need access to this object to this table
um and you you get to decide whether or
not you grant that uh permission to the
application and so here's kind of what
that looks like on the right just a
super quick screenshot of the
application of an application requesting
uh privileges um any admins in your
account would be able to review all of
the permissions that an app has
requested so you get to take full
control of exactly what the application
is doing your account and I mentioned
this earlier but you can optionally
share that those logs and Trace events
back to the providers in case they need
to debug it for something that may have
crashed in the app um something that
needs to be fixed maybe there's a bug or
something so that you can actually run
the app as
intended all right cool so that's the
gist of the snowflake native app
framework to quick quickly summarize
there are app providers who create the
app package it up and list it on the
marketplace there are consumers who find
those apps on the marketplace install
them in their account and run them in
their account on top of their data using
their compute so at this point you are
probably wondering what exactly does a
snowflake native application look like
and so I'm going to share my screen
really quickly to show you an
application that is
running in my uh snowflake account so
just give me a quick second
here so this is a snowflake trial
account that I spun up earlier let me
zoom in a little bit um and so I'm in
the app section of my account and if I
go here I see this native app quick
start app this is where I would see all
the installed apps for my account if I
click on that just let it warm up a bit
um it's warming up the wouse it's going
to make sure all the streamlet artifacts
are in place um and just basically uh
boot up to start running the application
this is that same application that I
showed earlier in that screenshot and so
it's loading up here as you can see
there's a tab here just called streamlet
I'm visualizing a lot of data that to my
account this entire front end was built
with just a few lines of streamlet so a
few lines of python using streamlet I
should say so we have these four graphs
right and we are visualizing some supply
chain
data and the scenario here is um this is
where we're going to be building towards
but it's really important to kind of
understand the scenario that's behind
the application um before we build it
and so the scenario today is that I'm
going to be playing the role of a uh ski
goggle manufacturer so I make ski
goggles and these ski goggles require uh
different raw materials to make and one
thing uh that is really important in
manufacturing these these uh ski goggles
is that I work with different vendors
and suppliers of those raw materials to
be able to actually manufacture these
ski goggles and so I am curious to
understand for example the performance
of individual suppliers you know is this
supplier better than that one I'm
curious to understand um how long is uh
plexiglass going to take um you know
from procurement to to to get shipped to
my front door before I start
manufacturing so I'm getting a kind of a
picture of the supply chain that uh is
behind the uh the ski goggles that I
manufacture maybe here I want to look at
the status of some of my purchase orders
so that's just kind of the gist of it
the provider is going to be like a
fictional supply chain company that has
shipping data so proprietary shipping
data on um exactly the lead times for
example for brass for aluminum for foam
and so the application is going to take
information that I have in my personal
snowflake account and enrich it with
with information that that proprietary
shipping information that the provider
will provide and then in the application
we'll kind of merge it to to create this
view here and give me as a Ski goggo
manufacturer the overview of what's
going on with respect to uh the raw
materials behind the ski goggle that I
that I manufacture so that's the gist of
it uh let me go ahead and stop sharing
my screen really
quickly go back to my other tab that I
had here just give me a quick second
please all right so there are two so the
two resources that you are going to need
if you are going to be following along
um are and I know I already dropped them
into the chat here but in case you
missed that let me show you exactly how
you can find them if you go to um quick
starts. snowflake.
comom and then go to the search bar and
type in Native apps you should get two
results back it's the second result here
getting started with snowflake native
apps I'm going to leave this open mostly
for reference I don't want to have to
manually type every single thing here
some of those things are conveniently
already in here and I just want to copy
and paste them in the interest of time
so I'm keeping this open as reference I
won't walk through these steps in order
or sequentially I'm just I'm keeping it
here in case folks who are using it need
to kind of Orient themselves in where we
are in the quick start and then also if
you quickly want to like copy you know a
code snipp it that's in here I can just
quickly tell you hey go to step 10 check
it out like copy that and paste it into
your snowflake account and then the
other the repo here is on github.com
snowlake laabs and then if you scroll
down to actually start searching for a
repo type in n uh Native
apps and it is this third result here at
the bottom SF guide getting started with
Native
apps so those are the two resources that
you'll need to be able to follow along
today during the
lab okay so with that let's go ahead and
get
started um let me go directly to let me
see here if you guys can see my code
okay awesome so all right so what am I
doing here this is the repo that
contains the source code for the native
application that we are going to be
building together um everything is
inside of this app folder and the
specific source code is inside of this
SRC folder and so what I wanted to do is
I've opened this up here in VSS code and
I have this this repo open here I wanted
to start by kind of going through some
of the key files that make up this
native application as you can see this
the source directory is pretty small um
and that is indicative of how little it
takes in some cases to actually be able
to spin up to author a a native app um
and publish it um into Snowflake and so
uh quickly just to show you what's going
on here I will start with the
UI scripts sorry I can barely see
here
streamlet P all right so um within the
libraries folder inside of the SRC uh
folder I've opened up streamlet dopy and
this is the file that represents the
entire front end for that native
application so everything that you see
here everything that you saw here with
the graphs and the title and the
formatting of the data that is all
defined in that one file that I had here
and so if I can see here this is 90
lines of python only Python and here
what we're doing is we're importing
streamlet because that is how we're
building the front end here for for the
native application snow
park we have this permissions SDK that
snowflake provides that you'll see in
action later today um I'm importing
pandas to do just a little bit of uh
Transformations here on some of the data
that's going to be in my account I have
a function here called app that is going
to load the Stream app given uh some
data so a couple of tables but then you
can also see here exactly how I'm
invoking streamlet to render some
components in the UI so here's that
spinner right whenever we're loading up
the app and it says loading lead time
order status so you know so forth and so
on st. spinner that's that's all it
takes to be able to render that and then
here if you're familiar with HTM HTML
and CSS you're probably used to using
flexbox and divs and moving stuff around
in grids similar kind of case here with
streamlet I use a container and then
inside of that container I Define two
columns right and then in those columns
I'm going to have my graphs and so if I
go back here I have two columns here and
then I'm H I have my my graphs in those
columns then you see some formatting
here I see some titles uh you see some
Transformations here against uh the data
frames that I had right see um and then
down here here's a title for the actual
application I say hey this is the orders
table we're going to use and the site
recovery table and then I invoke that
function I call it and say load app with
those two with those two tables and
that's all it's going to take to be able
to start running this application so I
thought I'd start with kind of the most
tangible uh piece of the application
which is a front end entirely defined in
Python in one file in less than 100
lines of
code the next next thing that uh I I
will go into here is a userdefined
function um a userdefined function is a
function that will execute inside of
snowflake but in this case I'm I don't
want to use SQL right I want to use
Python and so this is the way that you
would do it um I would I would write my
function in Python and then I would
Define it within Snowflake and say hey I
have a function that I want to execute
in uh in Snowflake it's written in
Python and then I would just kind of uh
create a reference to that function
within snowflake so that snowflake can
actually execute it as SQL and I'll show
you what that looks like in a bit I have
some two very three very basic um
userdefined functions here or udfs one
that calculates distance one that
calculates lead time and then just like
a sample one Duff hello world I don't
think we're actually going to use this
one in the application but I just wanted
to show here this is where I would
package up all my logic that would be uh
powering the
application I think we have a stored
procedures here this is for a billing
event it's not going to be invoked
because this is a trial count and this
is a sample application but as you can
see here if I wanted to create a bilding
event on say the number of rows and I
see it's commented out um you know this
is this is kind of like the boiler plate
that I might use to be able to start
thinking about how to do that we're not
going to invoke it in this uh
application um and I don't think this
file is going to be used at all but I
just kind of wanted to show another file
that's in this app um so that you can
see you know there's not a lot of magic
behind this this is just uh something
that I was toying around with but we
won't actually be invoking any billable
events for this application because it's
demo
app here's an environment yaml file
which is um going to Define any uh
dependencies that the native application
is going to need and so here all I'm
saying is hey I need the snowflake
native apps permission SDK to be able to
create a firsttime setup experience
which I'll demonstrate to you in a bit
I'll go back to this in uh as we build
the
application and then there are two more
two last files that I want to show you
that are super important um for the
native application framework the first
one is a setup. SQL file this is a
required file for all Native apps that
contains all the SQL setup all the setup
that the application is going to need to
be able to run when a consumer goes to
the marketplace and clicks install this
is what's running um under the hood it's
going to be what whatever the provider
defines in that setup. SQL file the way
I like to think about what's going to be
packaged in here is um roles permissions
and logic and so what which roles
exactly I'm the RO the roles that would
be defined here would be the roles that
the provider wants um within the
application so you could think of for
example an application that has
different roles with access to different
parts of the application I could come in
here as a provider and say hey I need
roll a b and c role a will be the admin
role B will have a subset of those
privileges role c will be even more
restricted for this application I'm only
defining one
role and then um I'm also going to be
defining some um give me one second so
my phone is
drinking
sorry I'm also going to be defining um
so I said roles um permissions and logic
I then make sure that uh my roles have
all the permissions that they're going
to need within the application to be
able to interact with different things
in the app I'll show you what that looks
like in a bit but here's also the logic
that I mentioned so um earlier I showed
you exactly what my UDF looked like the
one that says calculate lead time which
is in that UDF dopy file when I go back
to my setup. SQL script I have to make
sure that I create that and Define it
and say hey I have this calculate lead
time function that is going to be r that
is is written in Python running running
on python runtime 3.8 um it uses this
package and here is where it's defined
and in that file this is exactly what
that uh function is called so I'm just
kind of defining the logic here I do
that for each UDF that I have already
defined I have procedures here for
updating references this is for first
time setup I'll show you in a bit um you
really I really can't show first time
setup until we reinstall the application
and and you'll see what it looks like
then this code will make sense and then
here are the permissions that I
mentioned earlier so I want to make sure
that the application has access to the
right schemas the right tables the right
procedures that it has the right
permission to say run a select query on
a view that I'll create on data that
will be in my
account um and th those are the
permissions that the application will
also um will ask you for but also need
to just kind of operate as intended when
it's actually installed in your
account all right so uh the last and
final uh file that I'll go over before
we start building this is a manifest
yaml file this is a crucial part of your
application you're going to be defining
several it's kind of like metadata but
also references about the application
the metadata is you know the name of the
application the version of the
application the artifacts that this app
is going to requ to to refer to when
it's being installed and used
so we say hey the setup SQL script is
this file the uh front end is going to
be the the streamlet dopy file please
use that as a default front end this is
where as the app provider I'm can set
the log level or Chace level so for
those logs that if the Prov if the
consumer later wants to share back uh
with me you know I I would have turned
them on here and said hey I want to be
that application to generate logs um
logs that I can later uh use to
debug the application and then here I
have this references entry where um I
have an entry that represents the
objects that the application is going to
request permission to so here I have an
entry called order table and all I'm
saying here is hey I'm going to the
application is going to require select
privileges on a table um that is going
to contain orders data and all this is
is the definition of a reference
when I as a consumer install the
application in my account I will need to
bind that reference to the actual object
in my account and say hey you're looking
for this table here's a table that
contains that data whether or not it's
called orders ideally it is just because
it's going to be easier to find that way
but if it's not you know you go and you
just select you just manually map that
object to this
reference and then here is a call back
that we've defined and I showed this
earlier in the setup SQL script right
this update
reference uh procedure this is related
to adding removing um permissions to
these objects I will go back to this
later as we uh do the first time setup
for the application when all these
permissions are actually being
requested all right cool so that is so I
gave you an overview of the framework um
I demoed the app and then I've gone to
the source code now it's time to build
this application using the source code
and so just to get started the first
thing that I'm going to do is I'm going
to uninstall this application and I'm
going to drop
it and we're going to build it again um
using the source
code and then behind the application is
actually the application package and so
when an application package is
instantiated it creates the app so this
is the source code this is the package
that's behind the application um I'm
going to drop that as well because we're
going to create the application package
too and then there was there was a
database that I was using earlier that
contains data that the app is going to
use and it is here this native app Quick
Start database I'm just gonna throw it
all away so I'm going to drop
it and this other these other objects
that I have these other databases that
was just me toying around with other
other native apps um that I've built in
the past so I'll just go ahead and
refresh that so I don't have so just to
recap what I've I've uninstalled the app
I dropped the application package um
that is behind the app and then I also
dropped all the data that the
application is going to use so that we
can build this together okay so let's go
ahead and get started um I'm going to be
using cql worksheets within snowflake to
uh Define a lot of the things that the
application will need so basically to
prep the account so that the account the
application can run as intended later um
don't worry necessarily about um having
these exact same worksheets I will point
you to those cod snippits in a bit but I
just want to give you a heads up I'm
using worksheets you could go to
worksheet here you would quickly start
up a new SQL worksheet and then you
could you know type in whatever you want
in there so that that will be the flow
and then once you have one open you can
quickly create another one SQL or python
we're using SQL for the account setup
and so that's going to be the flow I've
already kind of pre-pre mine with the
codes Snippets that I need and these
codes Snippets are all in this quick
startart and I'm going to refer to these
um so you'll you won't get lost I'll
point you to the Cod snippet in here so
that you can go back and run
it okay awesome
so the scenario the scenario is again a
supply chain scenario provider is going
to be providing me with proprietary
shipping data around raw materials
the consumer is going to bring orders
data that they have right and so we're
using a single account today to mimic
both the provider and consumer uh side
uh of the experiences in practice there
would be two accounts right there would
be a provider account where they're
building the app and there would be a
consumer account where they are
downloading that app and installing it
but since this is a demo in a lab we're
using a single account to show both
sides and I'll tell you exactly when we
are when we have our provider hat on
when we have our consumer hat on so that
you can Orient yourself in this journey
so the first thing that we need to do is
we need to prep this account to contain
both the provider data that proprietary
shipping data and then also the consumer
data um so the proi so whatever the
consumer is going to have in their
snowflake account in this case the
shipping data all right and so the first
thing that we're going to do is we're
going to prep uh our account to uh
manually Define we'll Define these
tables and then we'll load the data into
these tables and so the first thing that
I do is I'm going to run this code
snippet which you can find
in the quick
start it
is Step eight it is this first code
snippet if you copy all of that and then
go
back to a SQL worksheet and paste it in
well looks like I didn't hit copy but
anyway I'm not going to go back and do
that again um this is where I am so it's
a code that is in step8 again
the top code snippet and I want to run
everything in this worksheet so I'm
going to go up to the top
right and hit run
all and I'm just doing a few basic
things here I'm creating a warehouse
that's going to power the
application I'm creating a database
called native app quickart
DB I'm creating a schema within that
database called native app quickart
schema and then I'm creating a table
called MFG shipping so the manufacturer
shipping data and I'm defining the
columns and their corresponding data
types and so if I go back actually I can
just do it here if I quickly refresh
this here's that database that was
created open that up here's that schema
that was created and here's a table that
was created so MFG shipping you can see
its definition here it's the exact same
thing that we ran in the worksheet
there's nothing in this table all we did
was create it and Define the Colum s
we'll go back and upload the
data shortly um and populate this table
with that
data all right so that is the
provider um uh table let's now Define
the consumer data so the consumer tables
we're going to do we're doing the exact
same thing we just did but now we're
putting our consumer head on and
defining the tables that the consumer
account would need to have so that the
application could run as intended and so
this
SQL if you go back to the quick start
and as I mentioned earlier I'm not going
in order I'm jumping around you would go
to step
10 let me zoom in a bit
here and it is this code snippet that
I'm copying so I'm copying this
here I'm going to go back open up a new
SQL
worksheet and drop that in
there
and now I'm going to run everything in
here and I'm doing very similar thing to
what I did
before um I'm using the warehouse that
we defined earlier the database and the
schema that we created earlier I'm
defining two new tables MFG orders and
MFG site recovery we can confirm that
they were created by going back to the
schema tables and then I'll hit
refresh and there they are are again
these are empty you can see I have this
note here we should go back and load
data into those
tables so not just for this um consumer
data but also for the provider
data and so it's pretty easy to do that
and so now for this next step where we
actually uh load data into these
tables you're going to be looking at a
folder inside of the
repo inside of app there's a folder
called Data these are CSV files that
we're going to load into the
corresponding tables now this is just
we're loading CSV files manually just
for the purposes of the demo in practice
this data would already exist in either
the Prov in the provider account and the
consumer account right in the
corresponding accounts I should say and
that data could have been ingested in
any which way that that provider or that
consumer uh you know used or prefers and
so I just want to show you where this is
inside the repo app and data because
when we go back to snowflake in the UI
we're going to be prompted to navigate
to this data so that we can load it into
those tables so let me go back here and
let's start uploading that data so I'm
going to click on data
databases native app quickart
DB native app quickart schema
tables MFG orders
so let's load the orders
data into this table all I did was click
load data at the top right I get this
model and I'm going to be using a CSV
file remember that so go
here is it recents as you can tell I've
been messing around a lot in
here give me a
second
Dev getting started with Native apps
great
okay so I'm going into the app folder
I'm going into the data folder this is
the orders table so order data
CSV and then I will click on
next and then here field that you don't
have to touch anything except for one um
field here so field optionally enclosed
by just hit double
quotes so let me just quickly show you
what that looks like
again um if I go
back I went and found my order data
which is going to go into the MFG orders
table I clicked on
next left everything alone the only
thing that I'm going to change is this
field
here make sure you set that to double
quotes and then and then now I will hit
load successfully
inserted here's a preview of that
data now let's do this for the other two
tables this is where I've seen some
confusion in the past where I've seen
folks actually go through this entire
lab and they get the app running but the
graphs don't show any data and they're
wondering why it's because they didn't
load the data into these tables so if
you skip the step you could in theory
you could still run the application but
there would be no data for the
application to reference or use or
visualize so this is pretty this is a
pretty important step so now let's do
the exact same thing for these other two
tables so MFG shipping load the data
shipping data
CSV click
next field optionally enclosed by double
quotes hit
load again another thousand rows here's
a preview
MFG site recovery same thing this is the
last one that we'll have to
load hit
next field option en Clos by double
quotes load that
up and we are
done okay so again we're prepping the
account to have both the provider and
the consumer data so that when we create
this application there is data for the
application to use again in practice the
provider would bring their own data
through the application the consumer
account already has that data but we're
using a single account today and so
that's why I'm showing you both sides
and that's why we're manually prepping
the account to have both data
sets Okay so now I'm going to go back to
my
worksheet um and if you just click on
any worksheet it'll just open up the
worksheets UI you can see all the ones
that I already have open here so I
didn't click on any specific worksheet
we we already ran 01 we already ran 02
where we defined those
tables now we're going to Grant what's
known as reference usage okay um I'm GNA
quickly double click on a concept here
that I I get a lot of questions around
which is hey I'm an app provider I have
this proprietary data that I would like
to share with my consumer how do I do
that in a safe and secure way um do I
just send this to them over email do I
email them CSV files do I give them my
cred you don't do any of that um the
snowflake naab framework allows you to
securely share um any proprietary data
any data um with a consumer using a
concept known as reference
usage that's what this worksheet does
and so what reference usage is is um
we're basically saying can you create a
reference to that data that's in the
provider account to that proprietary
data and then put that inside of a
schema create some views off of that
data and share those views in the
schema and then we'll give permission to
the application to use that schema and
those views so the consumer is never
going to directly access anything that's
in my personal provider account and
that's by Design there's absolutely zero
direct connection between the consumer
and the provider data and vice versa the
the data is owned um entirely by each
corresponding party and the reference
usage concept that I'll run in a bit
here enables providers to safely and
securely share data through the
application and then when the consumer
installs the
application the application has access
or you know reference access or
reference usage on my data on the
provider's data and so by using the
application the consumer is is
interacting with whatever the
application has access to in terms of
you know um select privileges um you
know anything that we've defined uh here
uh and I'll show you what that looks
like in a bit for that application to be
able to do against that proprietary data
so let's walk through uh the concrete
example here so we're going to use this
database right native app Quick Start uh
package we're going to create a shared
content schema this is a schema where in
which we will uh create create views and
then share that schema and the view to
the application package right and so
what we're doing here is I'm creating a
view called MFG shipping it's basically
selecting everything that's inside of
that MFG shipping table so again this is
that proprietary shipping data from the
from the
provider and then I just say hey U this
application
package um I want to Grant usage on the
schema and then share that in the
application package I want to Grant
reference usage to my proprietary uh
database and share that in the
application package and then I want to
Grant view privileges on the MFG
shipping table and share that in the
application package so the application
package will have references that point
back to my provider data and when the
consumer interacts with the app that is
how they get quote unquote access or
interaction with my
data um they never get direct access um
to the exact objects in the provider
account so I'm going to go ahead and run
all use database native at QuickStart
package ah a very silly mistake my bad
y'all so um there is no native Native
app Quick Start package uh defined yet
and
so let's go create it um if you go back
to apps so I'm going to create this
application package I'm going to go to
apps I'm going to create
packages right this is the key the key
part I skipped the step sorry if you
click app package here all we're doing
is just defining the application package
that's going to have uh the source code
in it and so I just want to make sure I
get the correct name here and I believe
believe it is
somewhere somewhere here well look you
could just get it from that worksheet
that I had open so go back to the
worksheet here's that here's the name
native unor app quickart package so I'm
going to go back to apps packages
and this is what I get for doing a live
demo all right so if I do
that create an app package here's the
name right as a provider I have the
option to distribute this to the world
anybody that's on
snowflake or I can distribute this to
accounts in my
organization I'm going to go ahead and
distribute this to everybody see if this
works I get an error and the reason I
get an error is because I'm using a
trial count and I that was intentional I
just want to show you that the trial
count you won't be able to uh publicly
list um your application but that is the
option that you would pick if you wanted
to publicly listed on the marketplace so
for today we're just going to hit
distribute to accounts in your
organization so this is super important
let's create our application
package all right now that we have an
application quick uh package I could go
here and add the first version but I
would get an error and the reason I get
an error is because we haven't yet
uploaded our source code that's going to
go inside of the application package and
there's a there's a required pattern
that you have to follow for this first
version model and experience actually
work so I created the application
package it's called native app Quick
package if you go back to data you will
see it show up here in the list of
objects now here you might expect
databases right well the application
package is actually a type of
database it's just a special database
you can see the icon is a little
different
and in this database or this application
package this is where we're going to
create upload our uh uh we're going to
upload our source code to and the way to
do this is you have to create a schema
you have to create a new schema in
here and then you'll create a stage and
that stage will contain the source code
so that is that is a way to actually be
able to um uh instantiate to actually be
able to create the first version of the
application package okay okay so I'm
going to create the
schema I believe you know I'm just I I
don't want to mess with the names again
so I'm just going to go
back and if you go
to
step give me a quick
second I think it's just native app
quick
start schema but I don't want to here it
is yeah so here it is so if you go to
step
eight doesn't really matter actually I
think what it's called let go back to my
worksheets just a double check Grant
reference
usage quick start TV quick start
[Music]
package
H okay let's just try this out so we're
going to go back to data native app
quickart package create a new schema I'm
going to call it
code inside of code I will
create a stage I'm going to go to Stage
this stage is going to contain my source
code you can call it whatever you want
I'm just calling it this I'm just Source
just so that I remember what it was
called later and that I know that it's
storing my source code okay all right
now so now I'm set up to actually
contain to to upload the source code
behind my application so again all I did
was go to Native app Quick Start package
create a schema called code create a
stage called
Source I'm going to go now and upload
the source code that powers my
application so the way that I'm going to
do that is just click on files up here
I'll hit browse
let's navigate back up to the rot of
this
repo I'm going to click on app and again
all my source code is inside of this
Source folder I'll start by I wish I
could just select everything but I can't
I need to individually uh select the
files um and later the folders so I'll
show you what that looks like so first
start with this outermost manifest yaml
file upload
that the next thing that I will do is go
to scripts that's a set of SQL script
that's
required and remember there was a f that
was inside of a folder called scripts so
I have to make sure that that folder
also exists in the stage I'll explain
why in a bit so you can see it creates a
folder called scripts
here give it a second and inside of that
will be my setup SQL file going to go
back and now upload everything that was
inside of libraries so everything and so
I'm going to say
libraries and then I have to make sure I
also create a folder here called
libraries
upload and now the directory structure
in my stage should match the directory
structure of the source code in the repo
so what you see in here should match
exactly what is inside of
SRC and the reason for that is because
the application has references that it
uses right to different artifacts and if
those break then the application will
break and it won't run as intended and
so now I have uh the source code for my
application in this
stage so now if I go
back uh to apps and I go to application
packages click on Native app Quick Start
package and if I hit that add first
version button I don't get that error
anymore all right and this was remember
this was erroring out now this
application package recognizes that I
have the correct setup in my application
package with the stage with the scheme
in the stage and the source code in
there and now I can add a first version
so super quickly what I did is I went to
my native app Quick Start package
created a code uh a code schema created
a stage called source and then I
uploaded the source code that was inside
of this Source folder start off with
manifest yaml and then the files in each
of those folders
all right so now let's go back to my
worksheets and let's see
here remember I we errored out last time
and we triy to you know I was trying to
use this database called native app
quickart package didn't exist so let's
see if we've resolved those errors and
we have all right and so I kind of
skipped ahead earlier this is the this
is the sequel that's actually granting
reference usage on that proprietary data
and allowing the application to use it
the application package to use it so
that the consumer can have uh can use my
data within that app but before I needed
to do that of course I needed to create
my application package so here's here's
that application package which contains
my source
code okay so now the application package
has reference usage on my
data the next thing that I'll need to do
is install the application excuse me um
in my
account now here's I skipped ahead
intentionally here on line 10 you see
that we're going to create an
application called native app quickart
app from our native app quickart package
application package using version V1 we
haven't yet defined that version but I
just wanted to show you what that line
of code look like because now you can
kind of map that to what we're doing in
the UI here so if I go back to my
application
package so apps packages native app
Quickstar package add your first
version
V1 right this has already identified
everything um except for the path go
here and say Hey I want everything
inside of that
stage hit
add all right I'm just going to hit done
I can't publish my app
package right and so here you see
version one one patch you can look at
all different all s settings around the
application package right the Privileges
um you could go here and and manually
modify them and say Hey I want a certain
role in my account to be able to have
develop privileges we're not going to do
this through the UI we're going to go
back and do that through SQL but as you
can see now we have a version we have
version one of our application uh
package now created so now if I go back
to my
worksheet right we want to install the
application which means we want to
instantiate the application package and
create an application based off that
this
SQL you would find in the quick start on
Step 11 so if you go to the quickart
copy the code block that is in Step
11 and take it back to the worksheet and
run
this so I'm going to hit run
all and pray to the demo Gods the live
demo gods that everything runs that as
intended
line 10 usually takes the longest
because it's creating the application
from the application
package not that it takes super long but
it takes longer than the other lines to
execute and then the last line on line
13 show applications I have that just to
sanity check myself and see whether or
not the application was successfully
installed all right we're at about 30
seconds there's nothing here that I
could cut to because this is the Moment
of Truth um this line needs to run it
needs to successfully execute um so that
we can install the
application in the account from that
application package and then have it
running okay so it ran took about a
minute um and then it ran that final
line as you can see I have native app
quick start app installed so
now moment of truth if I go to apps you
saw it quickly populate there native app
quick start app installed one minute
ago going to click on
it and it is booting
up and now you're about to see something
that you did not see at the very
beginning in the demo because I had
already set everything up you're going
to see uh the first time setup for the
application uh meaning that you're going
to see exactly what the application is
going to ask you um for a permission um
on so you'll see it say hey I'm looking
for this object called XYZ um can you
please map this reference to the object
in your account and those are the
references that you saw in that setup
SQL script so that's what it's
mapping this taking a little longer than
expected ah as soon as I said that it
decided to start moving cool all right
so here's that first time setup the app
would like privileges to access a table
in my account it wants select privileges
on the orders table can you map that
table okay select data everything is
inside of native app quickart TB inside
of this schema here native app quickart
schema orders all right and you see like
it's asking for an orders table the
table is called MFG orders on my account
it doesn't matter I'm doing the manual
mapping so I just say done save it's
probably going to ask me for more uh yep
so site
recovery site
recovery all right so it asked me for
permission to two tables in my account
that other table we didn't have to bind
because remember we are now playing the
role of the
consumer and so we just told the
application go use the these objects in
the consumer account that other table we
granted reference usage on that table to
the application package so I don't need
to map that that is already going to
come bundled with the application for
the consumer and that's how they'll be
able to to actually use that data um in
the in the
app and voila here it is we have the
application run
in my account and this is exactly what I
showed earlier at the very beginning uh
same
application with these for graphs lead
time status for certain orders lead time
statuses uh for orders that have taken
longer than two months the performance
of different suppliers here based on
according to lead time the status of
different purchase orders that I've made
has this order Shi you know how many
have shipped how many have been
delivered
all right and so just quickly to go back
to that first time setup when you saw me
here talking about streamlet
dopy and here's that permission
SDK right let me see here
permission this is that this when I
import snowflake. permissions as
permission that is going to unlock all
the things that I programmatically need
to be able to do that first time setup
and so like if I just show you the other
instances of permission in this file
you'll see here right um request the
reference for the order table using
permission right and remember that in
manifest yaml we Define the references
order table this label orders table you
saw show up in that UI here's the
Privileges we the application want
select uh privileges on that table right
to let the application know what kind of
object to expect here we say it's a
table table right and then you saw this
call back that we have over here in the
setup script update reference this is in
case I add remove or clear the reference
to that so if I were to go here I
mentioned earlier at the very beginning
I can always manage the access to
different objects in my account if I
really wanted to I can revoke this
privilege to this table as the app
provider hopefully you've built out some
error handling or some kind of fallbacks
in scarios here where if somebody does a
consumer does decide to not give you
access on this particular object then
the application should still you know
run as intended or in some other kind of
backup
way right but here I'm not going to
revoke this I want this to run
um let's see manage access this is for
roles I just realized I forgot to upload
one thing so as you can see this is
asking me for a readme there's no yeah
there's no readme file available but I
should have have uploaded the
readme that is in the
repo there's one I think there's another
one here inside of source I could be
wrong
scripts or maybe there's just no no read
me for this one but essentially if I do
upload this read me I mean we could
upload this one just as a
test then uh that read me would be
linked to from here and some of that
would be rendered as here as well and so
documentation for your native app comes
you know is is part of the UI uh here in
in the in the native
app all right
cool all right so that is it um so we
went from zero you know basically not
having anything to taking the source
code and creating this application that
runs inside of your snowflake account um
and I demonstrated both the provider
side and the consumer side of that I
just want to say just you know super
quick recap uh providers build the
snowflake native applications using
snowflake actually let me stop sharing
my screen here the super quick recap
providers are going to be building the
snowflake native apps using snowflake
Primitives streamlet for the UI
Snowflake and snow park for any kind of
logic and then other Primitives that you
have access to in Snowflake udfs uh
tasks external functions Etc everything
that's already available to you um in
Snowflake you can actually you know you
can still use as part of the Native app
framework providers will list and
monetize those apps on the marketplace
and then finally consumers install those
applications and run them in their
account so with that uh I just wanted to
say thank you so much again for joining
the session I hope you found it helpful
um if you would like the um again if you
have access to the resources that I
shared earlier if you want to follow
along and do this this ho this uh this
Hands-On lab um on your own time you can
go to the quick starts website that I
shared earlier and specifically look for
that one quick start uh and then the
repo is also linked to from that
quickart so it contains all the source
code behind that native app so thank you
again I really appreciate you joining me
um if there are any questions I'd love
to open it up if not you know feel for
you to drop them uh into the chat here
but again I just want to say thank you
so much for having me um really excited
to be here and thank you so much for
walking to this lab with
me right I'll wait just for maybe maybe
there's a couple of questions if not
then I'm happy to end the
session if you select a gcp in an
account you would have to go back and
spin up a new trial account um and
select AWS so I think I believe if
you've already created an account you
can't um you can't switch the underlying
cloud provider after it's already been
created you have to create another
one I'm looking at some questions what
are the
options of building a vector schema let
me show this on the stage what are the
options building a vector schema within
snowflake or what's on the snowflake
road map um for
llms um I can answer this as it relates
to Native applications so I touched a
little bit on this earlier um snow park
container
services um is a feature in Snowflake
that allow that unlocks really powerful
compute
for um training models or for training
uh bringing in llms if you'd like to and
so once snow par container services um
is uh available to use within snowflake
native applications then you would be
able to do those things inside of a
native application as well so you could
cons you could imagine a native
application that is running an llm and
that llm is part of a container and that
container is being run and executed um
using snow park container services so it
it would be a combination of several
features here um both Snowflake and
maybe you have your llm or you're using
a third party llm or using a snowflake
llm you know all that stuff would be
supported within that native app by
using a combination of these different
features is it possible to create an app
that writes user oh sorry let me show
this on the stage is it possible to
create an application that writes user
input back into the database so as far
as native apps are concerned that should
be uh possible um if you use the correct
components with streamlet and then as
long as you grant access to the right
access to the correct to the
corresponding objects to that
application then yes you should be able
to create an application that can insert
data now um keep in mind you might
depending on how widely you distribute
this right like you you have you might
have to account for uh different uh
objects exist existing already in
consumer accounts so um you may ask them
as part of your application to create a
database or a table ahead of time and
say hey make this application is going
to write to a table called it expects a
table called this so creating your
account um or you might do that as part
of your setup SQL script but in general
yes like this this is something that
should be supported um if you are able
to uh give that application right access
to the corresponding objects in your
account or in a consumer's account I
should say
thank you for your
question see
um this is um what if you want to make
an app for users that don't have a
snowflake account some way for external
users to access so with Native apps both
the consumers the consumer has to be on
snowflake to be able to use your native
app within snowflake but there are other
ways of building applications that don't
require the snowflake native app
framework and um would be available to
use by any user that's not on Snowflake
and the way you would typically do this
is by building your own custom API and
front end and then connecting that to uh
to Snowflake and so check out and so
that's outside of what the native app
framework um you know what I covered
today does but if you are interested in
doing that check out um basically
snowflakes ecosystem for uh and
developer platform where we offer uh
drivers to be able to connect
applications to snowflake to be able to
insert information to read from
it right um we have on quick starts.
snowflake. comom several quick starts
that show how to do this um the one that
I that comes to mind really quickly is
one that uh shows you how to build a
custom API using flask um and then also
that connects to snowflake using the
snow uh snow park for python or
optionally the snow park uh sorry the
snowflake connector for
python um so that is for like a web app
using the flask web app framework so
that's entirely in Python and then if
you want to do like a mobile app for
example there's also a quick start on
that so if you just go to quickstarts
snl.com and type in Mobile you'll see
exactly how the SQL API there is used to
build a mobile app um for like a
fictional use case of a food truck um
and then also just keep an eye out for
hybrid tables which will enable uh more
use cases uh more transactional use
cases um as you think about how to build
different apps that are powered by snow
lck so keep an eye out for that as well